ama
[Alkış]
değişmeyen tek şey değişimdir Bundan üç
sene önce Umut Çınar diye engelli
merkezleri ismimi bahsetme şahsiyet Adım
Adım Umut soyadım Çınar esasında hayatta
bazen öyle olaylar böyle olayları
titriyor ki inanmıyorsunuz ilk ve orta
öğrenimimi karadenizler ele geçirdikten
sonra liseyi İzmir'de üniversiteyi
Ankara'da okumak kırmızı oldu baba asker
olduğu için Türkiye'nin hemen her yerini
gezdik ama öyle olaylar beni öyle
yollara sürükler ince kendi Mesleğimi
ekonomi mezunu hiç yapma şansı
yakalayamadı Ben üniversiteden mezun
olduktan sonra part-time olarak bir
Fizikten Merkezi çalışmaya başladım
çalışırken de şunu söyledim kendime
güveniyorum dedim Çünkü rekabet çok
fazla herkes maaş tartışması yapıyor Ben
maaş istemiyorum Ben prim ile
çalışacağım ve burada var mı Ona göre
dekore edeceğim dedim ve oradaki film
ile çalışacağım dediğin olaydan dolayı o
gün işe girme şansı yakaladım ve çok
başarılı oldu çünkü bir ünlü bi
anlatırsanız ve markalaşma değerinde
yaparsanız o Önüne çok ciddi talepler
oluşu ama esasında hikaye en güzel
tarafı burada başlayacak Çünkü
engellilerin tedavi çok ihtiyacı olduğu
için merkezimize geliyorlardı o merkezde
bir gün yıldır ayarında bir Üstadım
geldi dedi ki mutlu eyledi benim bir
dernek Başkanlığı yaptığım yer var sizde
çok aktif temiz Sizden bir şey rica
edeceğim de bunu yılda ver dedim sizde
de benim bir bacağım bir kolum yok aynı
şekilde ayağa Kalkın bir sol bacağınızı
arkaya sağ konuda arkaya alır mısınız
dedi aldım temmuzdu şimdi dışarı
tekerleğinden bir pet şişesi alır
mısınız dedi Sıkıya zıplayın gittin
zıplaya zıplaya donuk amper içerisinde
kaldım belki de o güne kadar hiç fark
etmedim bir şey yaşadım yıl Ben dedim ki
gerçekten çok zorlandım dedim şimdi esas
de zorlanacağınız ikinci kısmına
geliyoruz şimdi Almış olduğumuz pet
şişeyi açar mısınız dedi
Harmanlı açma şansın bir şey olmadığını
gördüm O bana dedi ki Umut belli empati
yaptığınızda esaslarına kadar zor
şartlarda bizim çalıştığımızı veya
hayatımızı idame ettiğimiz gördüğünüz
dedi O yüzden sizlerin desteğinize
ihtiyacımız var dedi Ve o gün itibariyle
engellilere yaşlılara veya bunun
şeklindeki
kısıtlanmış durumda ki olan insanlara
yardım etme kararı aldım gönüllük
esasına göre çalışmaya başladım engelli
merkezinde gönüllülük esasına göre
çalışırken bir huzurevinde şiir
dinletisi vardı o şiir dinletisiyle de
hayatın komple değiştirdim kuzenin
içerisine girdim bir vakıfta ve o
Vakfı'ndan taşlarla o kadar iyi
anlaştığım ki tüm İşimi gücümü bıraktım
o Vakfı da nasıl başkanlığına geçtim ve
yaşlılarla yaşamaya başladım ilk 6 ay
orada kaldım bazıları ile aram çok daha
fazla iyiydi bazıları da yaşlılığın
getirmiş olduğu Azer vegas'tan dolayı
iletişim kuramıyorum Ama bir gün ablam
vardı aram çok iyi olduğu için her sabah
selamlaşıyor Gönül abla sabahın
altısında kalkıp makyajı yapan tam bir
hanımefendi bir gün selam verdim almadın
üzüldüm ikinci gün verdi verdim almadın
yine üzüldüm müdüre hanıma dedim ki
günahların bir sıkıntısı var Umut Bey
Nilgün abla 120 görüyor O yüzden siz ona
sesle takip etmediğiniz sürece onu siz
görme şansı yok dedi inanamadım hemen
ürün ablanın yanına koşmuş görme Abla
nasılsın dedim Umut Neredesin sen üç
gündür niye bana hiç merhaba dedin dedi
gün abla dedim Ne desen haklısın Seni
çok seviyorum dedim ve o gün anladım ki
iki defa hayatını değişiyor Çünkü yaşlar
için o çocuklar için engelliler için
yapabileceğimiz çok şey var ve o Vakfı
yönetim kurulu başkanı ile görüştüm
Kendisi çok Üstat ve duaya birisi dedi
ki bana unut dedi kendi derneğin
kurabilirsin Sonuna kadar yanındayım
dedi ve dernek kurmaya gittim dünya
yaşlılık Derneği adında çok da güzel
genç ekipleri dünyanın en genç yaşlı
Dayanın kurdum o yüzden bu Derneği
kurduktan sonra uluslararası başarıların
gelince dünyada bir anda mucize adam
dönmeye başladı Çünkü o kadar güzel
işler yaptık ki yaşlı kreşlere açtık
yaşlı köylerin kurduk ve dünyada sağlık
Turizm ne kadar önemli olduğunu
Türkiye'nin de dört mevsim olduğu için
bu dört mevsim içerisinde insanları
Avrupa'dan Türkiye'ye getirerek yaşlı
bakımı üstüne bileceğimiz Göster şu anda
biri üstünde yaşayan öpüyoruz bunları
diğer bir Yaşam Evleri'nde yapıyoruz
orta gelirli aileler için olan tuz
evlerimizde var ama bir su çok seviyoruz
yaşam ediyoruz yaşlıların de üst üste
dünyada Avrupa'da yılın dernekler öldüm
gelince çok ciddi bir markalaşma
sürecine girdi ve markalaşmanın ne kadar
önemli olduğunu anladım gerçekten
arkadaşlar markalaşma inanılmaz önemli
arkadaşlığımız zaman işlerimiz çok
gelişti ve Avrupa'da bazı danışmanlıklar
yapmaya başladık İngiltere'den
Almanya'ya kadar Yaşam Evleri kurduk ve
oradaki sistemleri dağıldık ve şunu
gördüm esaslı işin Özünde sevgi çok
önemli ve biz bir slogan oluşturduk 12
yaşlık ikinci çocuk yaşamıdır farkı
yaşanmışlıklar dır Çünkü yaşlı Türk
Lirası Tek fark bence tecrübeli biri
tecrübesiz ikisini de sevgiye saygıya
İlgiye ihtiyaç var Biz markalar
Derneği'nin yaşlı derinde markalaşmayı
bitirdikten sonra kurma kararı aldık
dünya markalar Derneğini kurduk O sordu
uluslararası lobi faaliyetleri yapmaya
başladı sağlık turizminde savunma sanayi
konusunda inanılmaz ülke için ve ülkeler
gibi dışarı çıkan bizim milli sermayemiz
için milli ve yerli ürünlerimiz için çok
büyük lobi faaliyetleri yaptık ve bugün
56 ülkede hep ithalat ihracat yapıyoruz
şunu gördüm ki hayattaki Kader çizgileri
insanın bambaşka Yolları götürebiliyor
Ama bu senin götürmesi yetmiyor Senin de
bu işin içerisinde
sürdürülebilirliği sağlamak güvenli
olduğunu etmen ve insanlara o hazzı
yatağı yaş atman gerekiyor Biz de dünya
markalar Derneği ile bu başarılı
perçinle şişince gün arkadaşlarımla
oturuyorum
bildirmemiz var Dünyam arkadaşlar besi
diye bir de bana dediler ki senin adını
Umut soyadın Çınar ikisini yan yana
getirdiğim zaman umutlar inanılmaz bir
etki yaratıyor bunun gibi bir şey
yapmayı düşünmedim mi dedi Şu anda 47
yaşında bunların Ne oldu Evet gittim
umutlar unutun Çınar'ın ikisini yan yana
getirmek 42 yıl boyunca düşünmüş hemen
pateni aldım Umur çınarı diye patentini
aldıktan sonra varlık durumu iyi olan
insanlara proje sunduk Çünkü ben yaşlı
konusunda çok iyiyim her şey çok
seviyorum ama elim geldi ayrı bir bakım
Umut Çınar adında engelli merkezleri
açıldı ve şu anda 1200 zeytin çocuğa
bakıyor hiçbir ücret alınmıyor Bunu
neden anlattım bazen insanlar kendi
elindeki imkanları bilemiyor olabilirler
Ben şu Sen izle bu kadar ustası Global
yatırımlara teşvikleri sebep olmuş bir
insanın bundan daha üç sene öncesine
kadar kendi adımı soyadımı yan yana
getirip onu göremedim Çünkü hayatta
işler o kadar hızlı ve akışkan geçiyor
ki bu akışkanlığını içerisinde
yakalamanız çok zor olabiliyor gençler
karıştırmayın söylüyor en başarılı olmak
için ilk önce inanmanız gerekiyor Betül
Mardin nasıl başladı halkla ilişkiler
diye bir kurum yoktur tırnaklarıyla
kızdı Bunun dışında binlerce başarı
hikayesi var aldık ağaçtan Onun dışında
dünya çapında işler yapan elim az
bunların hepsini tersine baktığımız
zaman ilk önceliklerini konular sonra da
Bu hedeflere gururla konuştular O yüzden
hedeflerimizi küçük kesinlikle koymayın
yapacağınız her olay başka bir olayı
sonunda tetikliyor tetiklediği olaylara
bambaşka birisi götürebiliyor Yeter ki
sürdürebilir mi sağlığın güveniniz
olmayı bir kere tarif edip sizin hiçbir
dediğimiz havada kalmamalı her
yaptığınızın arkasında durabilmeli siniz
geçen sene dünyada son trendlere
bakıyorduk arkadaşlarımızla birlikte
baktık ki yaşlı köyleri kuruluyor çok
enteresan bir şey Çünkü insanları tek
başına bir yaşamın ilçesi 370 bunların
içerisinde insanların çocuklarında
kalabileceği yerler olmalı yaşlıların
günü birlikte gireceğini yerleri olmalı
doktoru hemşiresi olmalı bu yaşlı
köyleri Konsept hakkını çalıştık
protokollere döktük
w2020 senesinde yaşlı kağıdında pat
aklımıza başvuru şimdi Türkiye'de yaşlı
köylü kurmaya başladı binlerce insan
istihdam edilecek O yüzden üretince
arkası geliyor şu anda Hollanda'dan
Almanya'dan Fransa'dan Amerika'dan gelen
yaşlılarımız var ve bir sloganımız var
yaşlılık ikinci çocuk yaşamıdır farklı
yaşamışlardır Neden Çünkü tecrübeyi yeni
nesil Eee aktardığımız zaman artık zaten
geliyor şu anda online eğitimler imizde
birlikte dünya markalar Derneği
üzerinden yaşlılarımıza bu eğitimleri
geçmesi aktarmaları için bir platform
kurduk ve yakın süreçte Tüm Türkiye'de
ve O da bu platform larımızı şifrelerini
Online olarak açmaya başlayacağız
amacımız değil mi amacımız birlikte
üretmek birlikte inanılmaz şeyler yapmak
küçük bir hikaye de olayı sonlandırmak
istiyorum Bugün Yaşımız geldi bana dedi
ki Ben 15 bir konuşma o yüzden size
yazarak vereceğim dedi Ve o yazıyı bana
verdi ya da şunu yazıyordu benim hayalim
Kutlu öğretmek bana bunun için bir
atölye yapar mısın dedi herkes benim
karşıma çıktı kıl testeresiyle kendini
Keser olur bu olur onun sana inandım
yanında gerekti teknik Ekipmanları
Teknik arkadaşlar da koydum kukla için
organizasyonu yaptık ve onu sonra aldım
TRT belgesel'de gittik bavula sığmaya
Hayatlar diye bir belgesini çektik Bunu
neden söylüyorum Çünkü hiç kimsenin
hayatı bir babasın O yüzden bizden Yarın
Başımıza bir dakika Bir saniye neler
geleceğini bilmiyorum O yüzden bu bilgi
birikimini çok iyi değerlendirmeli ve
insanlara aktarmalıyız Teknoloji çok iyi
kullanmalıyız ve bu teknoloji içerisinde
özellikle pembe mi süreçlerinde
insanlara yardımcı olmalıyız milli ve
yerli yapacağımız her şey yönlü
inanılmaz açın bakın bir profesyonel
ekibiyle yanına geldi a ki tarifi
ürünleri geliştirip Çünkü tüm dünyayı
takviye Gıda ve Kozmetik olarak
satılıyor zor bir şey mi herkesin evinde
olan bir hammadde bugün olan bunu
bilimsel olarak kriterleri oluşturmak
sonra bir pazarlamasını yaratmak O
yüzden Sizleri çok seviyorum İyi ki
varsınız Hep birlikte üretmeye devam
edelim saygılarımı iletiyorum Kendinize
çok iyi bakın
abone ol
[Alkış]